Traduttore: Emanuela Abate
Revisore: Helena Bedalli
Grazie
(Applausi)
Buongiorno, buongiorno a tutti.
Felix e la sua squadra mi hanno chiesto
di darvi un pò di contesto
per questa conferenza
per quello che succede qui oggi.
Allora ho pensato di parlare
per qualche minuto
di comunità, di apertura e di idee.
Se noi guardiamo alla storia
del progresso umano,
che è molto ben rappresentata
in questa sala.
Ci rendiamo conto che
il vero motore del progresso,
dell'innovazione, dell'avanzamento umano
sono le idee.
Ma sono soprattutto gli incontri di idee,
i confronti, gli scontri di idee
che poi generano e danno luogo a
idee nuove, migliori,
più innovative, più efficaci,
più forti
e quindi la storia
continua a progredire.
Ma c'è una condizione perché
le idee possano
incontrarsi, confrontarsi,
scontrarsi
ed è che circolino
apertamente e liberamente.
E a TED questa è un pò
la nostra missione
trovare e sviluppare dei modi
per aiutare
le buone idee a circolare
e a diffondersi.
E lo facciamo in molti modi.
TED nasce 27 anni fa.
Quindi c'è una lunga storia
dietro quest'organizzazione.
Per i primi 20 anni TED
è stata una conferenza annuale.
1000 persone in California
a confrontarsi su idee
dai settori della tecnologia
al design, dell'architettura
dell'innovazione e dei media
e dell'arte.
E poi nel 2005 abbiamo cominciato
a sviluppare attorno a questo
tutta una serie di altre attività:
una seconda conferenza annuale
TED Global in Europa,
un sito web TED.com,
dove le conferenze
come quelle che hanno luogo qui oggi,
gli speech di oggi,
sono poi distribuiti a livello mondiale
con sottotitoli in dozzine di lingue
in formato video gratuitamente
ma anche una collezione
di libri elettronici
una "fellowship" un premio annuale,
collaborazioni con aziende
e con cartelle televisive
e naturalmente il programma TEDx
di cui fate parte oggi.
Tutto questo converge un pò
in questa idea di creare
una piattaforma globale
per identificare e per diffondere
apertamente, liberamente,
gratuitamente
nuove e buone idee.
Appunto con quest'idea,
con questo concetto in mente
che le idee possano veramente
costituire il motore del progresso
e dell'avanzamento umano.
TEDx è una parte fondamentale
di questa piattaforma
è un programma
che abbiamo iniziato
due anni e mezzo fa.
TED è un'organizzazione no profit
è una fondazione basata a New York
con attività internazionali
e negli anni siamo stati
sollecitati sempre di più
per andare ad organizzare
conferenze in altre parti del mondo.
E naturalmente non possiamo
moltiplicare molte conferenze
però abbiamo trovato un modo
chiamato TEDx
per permettere a dei membri
della comunità di TED,
a livello locale e in modo indipendente
di organizzare la loro propria conferenza
esattamente come questa
in modo totalmente indipendente
ma sotto il marchio TEDx
e seguendo il modello
delle nostre conferenze,
cioè un modello che si vuole
non politico, non commerciale,
non religioso
quindi non vuol dire che non
parliamo di politica
o che non parliamo di impresa
o di economia
vuol dire che non è un luogo
per promuovere un prodotto
o per promuovere una campagna elettorale.
É un luogo per discutere
e per condividere idee.
E quindi in questa direzione
abbiamo offerto la possibilità
a chiunque condividesse
quest'intenzione
di organizzare il loro evento
utilizzando il marchio, i metodi,
eccetera...di TED
in modo gratuito.
Quindi non è per noi un modo
per guadagnare dei soldi
è un modo veramente per
allargare la piattaforma
e la comunità.
E quello che è successo è che
noi ci aspettavamo
una trentina, una quarantina
di conferenze nel primo anno.
Eravamo molto contenti
di questa prospettiva
perché improvvisamente
avremmo avuto
una piattaforma molto più vasta.
Quello che è successo è che
ne abbiamo avute 2500
in 111 paesi
in 46 lingue
in luoghi come questi
da Stoccolma a Jakarta
dalla NASA
alla sede del Parlamento Europeo
da Ginevra alla Tunisia
del prima e dopo rivoluzione
quindi dicembre e marzo
dicembre dell'anno scorso
marzo di quest'anno.
Oggi stesso c'è un TEDx
a Baghdad, in Iraq
eccetera...
2500 avvenimenti
di tutti i tipi.
Grandi come questo,
piccoli, 50 persone,
in sale spettacolari come questa
o in palestre scolastiche,
in teatri, in municipi,
centri congressi,
organizzati in modo molto
professionale
o meno professionale.
Ma non ha importanza,
quel che ha importanza
veramente
è che tutti muovono
da una stessa intenzione
quella di ritrovarsi e condividere idee
nella convinzione che
le idee hanno un potere
per muovere le cose.
Tutti questi elementi
sono organizzati in modo
assolutamente indipendente.
Noi a TED non svolgiamo nessun ruolo
altro che dare il marchio,
il formato, metodologia
e un certo tipo di strumenti
agli organizzatori locali
quindi quello che vedete qua oggi
è tutto merito di Felix e la sua squadra
e noi non c'entriamo proprio nulla
e penso che hanno fatto un ottimo lavoro.
Bravo Felix.
(Applausi)
L'altra cosa interessante che è successa
è che rapidissimamente questo modello
non soltanto si è diffuso nei numeri ma
è arrivato in luoghi
che non ci aspettavamo
di toccare.
Questa è Kibera
è la più grande bidonville
d'Africa, a Nairobi
un milione di persone ci vivono
e lì in mezzo
da qualche parte
una di quelle capanne è utilizzata
come centro di ritrovo della comunità.
Il primo TEDx si è svolto nel 2009, lì.
Questo è un giovane imprenditore,
Tonee Ndungu,
che ha voluto raccontare
la sua esperienza
come ha fatto prima
Selene su questo palco.
Ce n'è stato un paio d'altri interventi
hanno visto un paio di video
e hanno discusso.
Da allora ce ne sono stati altri
e TEDx era un pò un
catalizzatore di innovazione
all'interno di questa comunità.
Questa è Fatehpur nel Rajasthan in India
una cittadina indiana come tutte le altre
salvo che lì vive una ragazza,
una donna trentenne ormai
Masarat Daud
all'epoca, due anni fa
quando ha cominciato
ad interessarsi a TEDx
era non sposata.
E voleva portare TEDx nella sua città
e si è scontrata con una quantità
di problemi, di ostacoli, di resistenze
Perché?
Perché una giovane donna
musulmana non sposata
non era veramente la persona
più adatta per salire su un palco
e organizzare e presentare
una conferenza con
degli speaker maschi,
degli speaker uomini.
Ma ha superato gli ostacoli,
ha continuato ad andare avanti
ed ha attirato 1000 persone
al suo avvenimento in Rajasthan.
Oppure a Gerusalemme
dove una donna palestinese,
una donna israeliana
che non si conoscevano fino a
quando si sono incontrate a TED
hanno deciso di organizzare
assieme TEDx Holyland
TEDx Terra Santa
con degli speaker soltanto donne
non per parlare di Israele e di Palestina
ma per parlare di architettura,
di design, di educazione
eccetera...
quindi di soluzioni per problemi.
O in Amazzonia, in quell'hotel sul fiume,
a un'ora a nord di Manaus
con partecipanti da tutti
i paesi amazzonici.
O ancora, ultimo esempio
un modello sviluppato dalla
comunità di organizzatori di TEDx
non da noi
degli avvenimenti come questo
ma per i giovani
sul palco e nel pubblico
in occasione delle giornate
della gioventù
dichiarate dall'ONU ogni anno
a fine novembre.
Questa era l'anno scorso
60 avvenimenti per giovani
in giro per il mondo.
Quest'anno fra pochi giorni
più di 120 avvenimenti
in giro per il mondo
tutti generati dalla comunità
di organizzatori di TEDx.
Questi sono gli avvenimenti TEDx
già annunciati per i prossimi 6 mesi.
Dove c'è la crocetta rossa
vuol dire che non ci sono più
biglietti a disposizione.
Questo vi dà non soltanto un'idea
della distribuzione mondiale
ma vi dice anche che continua
ad esserci una grande sete
per questo tipo di cose
per la capacità di confrontarsi
in uno spazio neutro
dove nessuno cerca di vendere nulla
ma dove tutti cercano
di contribuire delle idee
di ascoltare quelle degli altri
e assieme di renderle migliori.
Grazie mille per averne fatto parte.
Grazie.
(Applausi)